أحد الأشياء التي ناقشتها
مع الرئيس بايدن عندما التقيتما هنا
في نيويورك كان هذا الاتفاق المحتمل
لتطبيع العلاقات مع المملكة العربية السعودية الذي
سمعناه من ولي العهد الأمير محمد بن
سلمان، حيث يقول إنه يعتقد أن المحادثات
تقترب، ما مدى التقارب في رأيك؟
سأقوم بالسرقة
سأقول إننا نقترب كل يوم وما
مدى قربك اليوم
مما كنا عليه بالأمس، هل
تشعر أن الصفقة محتملة؟ أعتقد أنه من
الممكن؟ أعتقد أنه من
المحتمل لأنه  أعتقد أن إسرائيل والمملكة العربية
السعودية والولايات المتحدة تشتركان في
هدف مشترك لتغيير التاريخ لجعل
هذه القفزة الكمية قفزة نوعية أخرى
للسلام، كما حدث مع
اتفاقيات أبراهام مع الولايات المتحدة،
ولدينا الآن فرصة مع
الولايات المتحدة لتغيير الوضع.  الشرق الأوسط
إلى الأبد
ليس فقط ليس فقط
لإسقاط جدران العداء ولكن أيضًا لإنشاء
ممر لأنابيب الطاقة
وسور كابلات الألياف الضوئية بين آسيا
عبر المملكة العربية السعودية وجورجيا
وإسرائيل والإمارات العربية المتحدة هذا أه هذا
تغيير مذهل  وأنا
دائمًا حريص على هذه الأشياء، ولن
أبالغ أبدًا، وأعتقد أن هذا هو محور
التاريخ، لكن بالطبع أي صفقة مع
السعودية ستتطلب شيئًا
مقابل الفلسطينيين، ما هي
التنازلات المهمة التي أنت على استعداد
لتقديمها لهم؟  لا أعتقد أن هذا
تبادل، وأعتقد أن بإمكانهم الاستفادة من
هذه القطعة وأعتقد أنهم ارتكبوا
خطأً في عدم الانضمام إلى
اتفاقيات إبراهيم، وكما تعلمون، إبعاد
أنفسهم عنها، أعتقد أنه
سيكون من الحكمة الدخول في هذا الأمر ورؤية ذلك  كيف
يمكنهم أن يكونوا جزءًا من العملية، جزء
من العملية، لا يعني أن
لديهم حق النقض على العملية
لأنه إذا كان لديهم حق النقض على
العملية، إذا كان لديهم مثل هذا في حالة
اتفاقات أبراهام، فسنقوم بذلك.  لم يسبق لنا أن
حصلنا على اتفاقيات أبرام، وسنمضي
ربع قرن آخر من دون
سلام، لذا لا توجد حق النقض، لكن هذا ما
لستم على استعداد لفعله، وما الذي أنتم على
استعداد لفعله، وما الذي ترغبون في
تقديمه للفلسطينيين بشكل جيد على وجه التحديد  كما
تعلمون، هذه هي الأشياء التي
ناقشتها مع المنتديات المنفصلة من
أجل الحصول على نتيجة حقيقية، فمن
الأفضل بكثير إحضار
الحزمة بأكملها ولمرة واحدة ولكني سأقول هذا
وأعتقد أنه من المهم أن
نصنع السلام مع السعودية.  المملكة العربية السعودية
والبدء في إنهاء
الصراع العربي الإسرائيلي سيساعدنا أيضًا على إنهاء
الصراع الفلسطيني الإسرائيلي
وأعتقد أن هذا ما يفتقده الناس
يعتقدون أوه لا، عليك أولاً إنهاء
الصراع الفلسطيني الإسرائيلي
ثم الانتقال إلى العالم العربي ماذا  ما يسمى
النهج من الداخل إلى الخارج أعتقد أن النهج
من الخارج هو الذي لديه
فرصة أكبر بكثير لإنهاء مجموعتي
الصراعات مع الدول العربية ومع
القصر، ولكن ما هو مطروح على الطاولة هو
فتح القنصلية الأمريكية وإعادة فتحها
في القدس الشرقية  بالنسبة للفلسطينيين، هل
هو تجميد المستوطنات في
الضفة الغربية في المناطق المخصصة
لهم؟ أعني هي تلك الأشياء المطروحة على
الطاولة من وجهة نظرك،
حسنًا أولاً، أيًا كان ما هو مطروح على
الطاولة، لن أعرض
مصالح إسرائيل الوطنية وأمننا للخطر ولكن
كما أنني لن أعرض النجاح للخطر من خلال
التحدث عنه علنًا حتى على شبكة سي إن إن